[Música]
con nuestra segunda invitada del día
hablamos de la situación de los
migrantes venezolanos en Costa Rica el
presidente de ese país Rodrigo Chávez
anunció que decidió restringir el
ingreso de extranjeros que emigran por
razones económicas como es el caso de
estos venezolanos en los últimos meses
por lo que el gobierno prepara entonces
una carta no para las Naciones Unidas
para decir que no han colaborado lo
suficiente con ese país saludamos
entonces a nuestra segunda invitada del
día Ella es Tania Molina rojas consultor
en seguridad y criminología egresada del
centro hemisférico defensa William Shake
Perry en Washington DC además sobre
kimengo organizado y Derechos Humanos y
estado derecho gracias a Tania por estar
con nosotros está mañana de martes aquí
en directo América de Francia 24 muy
buen día
muy buenos días Muchas gracias por el
espacio Tania hablemos de esta situación
entonces de los migrantes venezolanos en
Costa Rica en estos últimos meses y por
qué esta decisión del gobierno del
presidente Rodrigo Chávez de restringir
este acceso a los migrantes además de
hacer una nota de protesta antenaciones
unidas Bueno más que restringir las
fronteras o estar tomando decisiones de
algún tipo arbitrarias en realidad lo
que se manifestó por parte de
presidencia y de cancillería es una
preocupación es un llamado de atención a
las autoridades internacionales
principalmente por supuesto a Naciones
Unidas y al acnur que es por supuesto
quien lleva adelante toda la estrategia
y el acompañamiento para las personas
migrantes Costa Rica se ha caracterizado
a lo largo de la historia por ser un
garante de los derechos humanos y por
supuesto Siempre también ha acompañado a
las personas que se desplazan que se
movilizan por el territorio hacia los
Estados Unidos Lamentablemente a partir
del cambio abrupto que da en Estados
Unidos con estas nuevas políticas y
además algunos de los países de
Centroamérica Pues por supuesto esto
promovió que los venezolanos
particularmente que se estima además que
son aproximadamente
200.000 personas que han estado
transitando en los últimos meses y medio
aproximadamente dos meses se quedaron de
alguna forma parados en el país en
teoría la pretensión era únicamente
pasar por acá histórica sucedido Pero
ahora con las políticas de Estados
Unidos están en Costa Rica están en las
vías públicas en condiciones de
precarias verdad Entonces si hay una
gran preocupación por parte del país y
por parte de las autoridades también de
seguridad puesto que ya se han visto
algunas manifestaciones también aisladas
de violencia Entonces el llamado es de
atención no es un bloqueo de fronteras y
tampoco pues se van a tomar decisiones
arbitrarias en cuanto al otorgamiento de
la condición de Refugio que Costa Rica
siempre igual como uno de los países
principales No sólo en América Latina
sino en el mundo
porcentualmente somos uno de los países
que más Refugio otorgan claro también
Tania esta situación pues complicada de
los migrantes venezolanos como usted
bien lo dijo que buscaban su sueño
americano que se han quedado en los
países sobre todo Centroamericanos
también en Panamá ya hay gobierno
panameño ha enviado vuelos con destino a
Venezuela para una cierta reparación
también hay migrantes varados en México
pero el gobierno también devolviendo el
caso costarricense del presidente Chávez
dice que de alguna manera se estaba
usando este sistema de refugiados en el
país que qué clase de abusos A qué se
refiere con esta declaración Tania
las manifestaciones que hace presidencia
tienen que ver estrictamente con las
características verdad las condiciones
específicas con las que siempre se ha no
solo se llena el formulario para
eventualmente ser parte de esa condición
de Refugio sino que el manifiesta todas
estas personas que pasaban por Costa
Rica son de alguna forma aunque esté mal
llamado migrantes económicos y no
obedece asuntos políticos por lo tanto
desde ese foco es que se está diciendo
que se están aprovechando de alguna
forma de esta condición para solicitar
el refugio y por lo menos en este país
con solo que usted haga la solicitud de
Refugio ya usted queda en una lista de
espera y por lo tanto puede quedan un
limbo pero no puede ser no puede ser
sacado del país verdad entonces lo que
manifiesta Don Rodrigo Chávez el
presidente es una preocupación puesto
que ellos al sentirse y quedarse parados
por la obstrucción a partir de lo que
manifestó vaiden en Estados Unidos y
además países de Centroamérica no ha
sido solo Costa Rica de ya no pueden
pasar por acá ya no podemos sostenerlos
Rodrigo Chávez dice todas estas personas
que solamente iban a trasladarse no
pueden solicitar Esa condición de
Refugio que es más un asunto político
como lo que nos ha pasado principalmente
con Nicaragua a partir de abril del 2018
que la solicitud de refugios se han
disparado verdad Entonces que no se vaya
a confundir Esa condición de refugio
político por Refugio económico son
personas que quieren quedarse en Costa
Rica para trabajar claro Tania ante Este
cambio de Panorama Digamos que ya
evidentemente no pueden llegar a Estados
Unidos Si no es por otra vía aérea bueno
con las condiciones del gobierno de Joe
biden ellos podrían cambiar actualmente
su estatus migratorio dentro del país es
decir Bueno yo evidentemente quería
llegar a Estados Unidos ante esta
negativa Ya me tengo que quedar en Costa
Rica y quisiera manifestar la intención
de quedarme en este país para buscar
Entonces el asilo acá y poder hacer una
vida acá eso es posible un cambio está
tuyo migratorio
está siendo posible porque muchos de
ellos efectivamente incluso no han
manifestado medios de comunicación
verdad saben que Costa Rica es un país
que por supuesto suscribe Los acuerdos
internacionales sobre temas migratorios
y los Derechos Humanos Porque además
hemos sido siempre un representante al
más alto nivel en cuanto a esos términos
Y por supuesto por ser una democracia
sólida un estado de derecho y muy
convalidado saben que pueden
perfectamente permanecer acá se les está
invitando con autobuses para que se
puedan trasladar hacia Panamá pero es
absolutamente voluntario entonces
efectivamente Hay un gran número de
venezolanos que se van a quedar en Costa
Rica y se les están facilitando las
herramientas para que lo puedan lograr
no es que se van a sacar o se van a
obligar a trasladarse a Panamá solo se
está diciendo y se está haciendo un
llamado de atención e incluso desde la
seguridad nacional desde la dirección de
inteligencia Y seguridad nacional el
Ministerio de seguridad pública también
se está manifestando una preocupación
puesto que perfectamente las
organizaciones criminales pueden
aprovecharse de toda esta esta coyuntura
y que ya lo hemos visto toda América
Latina verdad entonces pues sí hay que
poner un foco muy especial
principalmente por el asunto de la
seguridad pero Porque además ellos no
pueden estar en las vías públicas en
este momento son las organizaciones tipo
religiosas las que están acompañando
mayoritaria a los venezolanos pero no no
es que Costa Rica los va a expulsar o va
a cerrar las las fronteras Sí también
hay que decir que se hizo desde la un
llamado de atención para Colombia para
que de alguna forma Colombia pueda dar
soporte acompañamiento
de algún en algún momento en el Darién y
no faciliten pues más lentos Porque si
es es una crisis en este momento sin
duda una crisis inmigratoria sin
precedentes que nuestra región de
América Latina y el Caribe Tania gracias
por su tiempo por estar con nosotros en
directo América un abrazo con mucho
gusto un placer